je suis très attristé et je ne suis pas
surpris attristé de voir ce beau pays
qui est la France se disloquait sous nos
yeux ce qu'on a nos assistons à un
disque location sociale n'est pas
question de pauvreté ou de inégalités
les jeunes comme on les appelle ont
attaqué Nike et Apple ils ont pas
attaqué Intermarché Carrefour ils ont
pas volés qui ont été vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai mais
c'est mais on peut pas enfin je viens
d'un milieu modeste moi aussi et nos
parents ne volaient pas je ne vois et
puis la pauvreté il est chez moi au
Maghreb ou là vraiment
il est vrai inégalités vous avez des
gens qui qui crient le règne de la
France d'ailleurs personne n'a parmi ces
jeunes a dit on attaque parce qu'on est
pauvre il dit ah bah la France on n'aime
pas la France on est chez nous et puis
vous avez aussi dans notre côté ce que
j'ai dit appeler ce matin un looping
prolétariat vous avez une jeunesse ou
une enfance c'est très triste d'ailleurs
une enfance disponible pour faire
n'importe quoi
pour l'aventure
comment on en sort
je vais vous casser le moral on en
sortira pas il faudra vivre avec la
menace du séparatisme puisque nous avons
en France un choc des civilisations avec
la menace du séparatisme on peut en
sortir avec un séparatisme
moi je pense que la mission de ma
génération ce n'est pas de baisser les
bras mais ce n'est pas de vivre dans le
monde d'avant dans le conservatisme il y
a une menace de séparatisme à nous de la
conjurer mais elle reviendra toujours
comme une crise d'herpès est-ce que vous
avez en France plusieurs civilisations
qui sont en concurrence pour le même
territoire suite à l'immigration de
masse vous avez une civilisation
française qui est en crise la sa propre
crise vous avez une civilisation
maghrébine et africaine qui se considère
les trois égales légitimes et ça donne
ces explosions là moi ce que j'appelle
les débordements d'égouts de temps en
temps ça sort donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire il faut essayer de de
diviser à terme de désactiver cette
pulsion là de du séparatisme plusieurs
mesures notamment essayer de promouvoir
deux choses je dirais pour être très
très pratique un peu caricatural je m'en
excuse il faut sévir sur les éléments
les plus récalcitrants mais sévir les
neutraliser par la loi
voilà les sortir de ces faux l'état
d'urgence je suis pas
constitutionnaliste je mais moi je pense
qu'il faut aller au-delà de je pense que
tu as d'urgence me servir à rien à mon
humble avis ce qu'il faut c'est une
nouvelle doctrine du maintien de l'ordre
dans les banlieues il faut que le préfet
le tribunal le juge soit visible des
populations et siège en mon lieu parce
que aujourd'hui l'État c'est banlieues
sont sous administrés qu'est-ce que je
veux dire parce que de toute façon
publique sont brûlés il faut revenir il
faut revenir parce que l'état d'urgence
parce que il faut que les populations
revoient l'État et l'honneur de l'État
nous on les gave de bonbons j'exagère on
met des bonbons c'est à dire les
allocations la médiathèque les
bibliothèque que font ces populations
faut pas les généraliser enfin pas
généraliser mais que font ces jeunes il
brûle ce qu'on leur a mis ils ont besoin
d'être gouvernés ça veut dire de limite
il faut qu'on mette des limites ça veut
pas dire l'autoritarisme c'est ça que
j'aime pas le la question doit être à
d'urgence mais que l'État revient en bon
le l'état régalien et nous avons quand
même une tradition en France
de maintien de l'ordre sans être
fasciste c'est juste une question de de
bon sens on a entendu tout à l'heure
Gérald Darmanin est-ce que vous le
croyez quand il parle d'un recul de
l'intensité ce qu'il a fait samedi puis
dimanche
c'est quoi vous savez c'est comme le
nombre de viols si les femmes victimes
de viol ne déclarent pas les viols on a
l'impression qu'il y en a moins bon là
on nous dit il y a moins
d'interpellation est-ce que c'est les
policiers qui sont plus moins moins
motivés pour interpeller ou est-ce que
vraiment il y a une recule je sais pas
donc vous y croyez pas je ne crois pas
je ne crois pas dans Monsieur Darmanin
depuis l'histoire du Stade de France où
il a confondu les Afghans avec d'autres
populations je crois plus avec les
Britanniques la cagnotte de soutien aux
policiers de Nanterre atteint au moment
où on se parle plus d'un million d'euros
à dépasser le cadre d'un million d'euros
quelles leçons vous en tirer
une leçon qu'il y a dans ce pays une
opinion publique refoulée brimer
souterraine
et il y a aujourd'hui en France des gens
qui ne sont pas dans le consensus
médiatique il se cache et qu'est-ce que
vous appelez le consensus médiatique je
vais très très franc c'est un consensus
qui est globalement anti-français c'est
à dire que tout ce qui fait mal à la
France il est sur
un peu
exagérées
le cadre européen est meilleur que la
France la France a colonisé la France
doit être aérée la France
[Musique]
a colonisé c'est sûr mais bon les
Marocains nous avons colonisé le Mali
bien sûr tout le monde a colonisé même
les mêmes les Anglais ont colonisé les
Irlandais
alors Christian nous dit mais monsieur
driz Galli vous êtes vous êtes naïf avec
respect alors Christian Léon dites nous
pourquoi vous pensez que
vous pensez que Driss Galli et naïf moi
quand je lis votre livre j'ai pas tout
lu mais enfin profiter pour regarder de
nouveau votre livre et je pense que vous
enfin on peut dire tout des pâtes naïf
en tout cas vous avez vous avez des
solutions vous en proposez moi j'ai une
question est-ce qu'il faut un nouveau
plan banlieue non pourquoi ce que le
problème n'est pas un problème de ciment
de de plastique et de vitres et de
tramway donc ça vous faites allusion à
ce que étaient les plans banlieue qui
était d'attendre reconstruction et de et
de rénovation des notamment des
habitations des immeubles et de dans
l'ensemble de ces quartiers non c'est
pas le problème c'est c'est je pense que
40 ans d'erreurs devrait quand même nous
ouvrir les yeux il faut deux révolution
une révolution de la doctrine du
maintien de l'ordre c'est-à-dire ce
n'est pas seulement la police de
proximité c'est l'autorité de proximité
vous croyez la proximité une fois qu'on
a enlevé les éléments les quand il y a
quelqu'un qui porte une kalachnikov il
faut pas de police de proximité
quand il y a un dealer avec 20 une 20
bandits qui tient une cité on peut pas
mettre la pause à proximité la poste à
proximité est une étape
ultérieure à la reprise en main
et alors en prison main profonde des
quartiers ce n'est pas seulement
éliminer les éléments les plus les plus
dangereux c'est
voir des racines et tous les les choux
comme on appelle les guetteurs les fonds
appliquer la loi ce que plusieurs de nos
juges ne veulent pas faire et construire
des prises le problème c'est ça pour
vous c'est que le problème c'est il est
judiciaire et les prisons portant elles
sont surpeuplées parce qu'on en fait pas
ce que nous avons une société de plus en
plus criminogène et c'est donc c'est
normal qu'on nous prions soient sur
peuplée il aurait fallu il faudrait en
construire plus
est-ce que vous pensez qu'on est dans
une situation de guerre civile
bon après moi je suis plus de séparatif
de communauté on peut déraper vers la
guerre civile on peut on peut y aller
ce sont des choses on est dans le monde
de l'irrationnels de l'émotionnel on
peut pas le prévoir mais le risque
séparatiste il pointe à mon avis très
très près de nous
certains certains policiers nous dit que
le disent ne méritent pas leur place
dans les forces de l'ordre est-ce que
c'est votre point de vue aussi
je suis certain que la police nationale
la gendarmerie aussi souffre de
l'effondrement du niveau de nos
fonctionnaires et de nos cadres dans la
de l'éducation nationale nous avons vu
le l'épisode du covid l'épisode des
gilets jaunes nous avons vu la police
qui a abusé de son autorité mais je
pense que globalement la police
moi très sincèrement j'étais choqué en
tant que citoyen quand je vois un
policier français mettre une amende à
135 euros pour quelqu'un qui se balade
dans Paris je pense qu'on est au-delà de
l'État de droit ils ont appliqué les
hommes sont pas légitimes est-ce qu'il
faut envoyer l'armée
aujourd'hui non me semble-t-il enfin je
suis pas à la place bobo me semble-t-il
et puis l'armée a une tradition de
maintien d'ordre en France mais il faut
la préparer sinon on aura un carnage
parce que le soldat tire
est-ce qu'il faut aggraver les sanctions
contre les parents des mineurs
délinquance la question qu'on pose sur
le site du Figaro ben je vais vous dire
je n'en sais rien parce que très
sincèrement
j'ai envie de punir les parents mais
j'ai l'impression que il n'y a plus de
parents j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont on
va punir des gens qui ne sont plus
écoutés par leurs enfants parce que à
quoi ça sert de punir le papa ou la
maman c'est pour que le papa et maman
rentre au présent sur son enfant moi
j'ai vu des situations dans le travail
où vous avez des mamans complètement
dépassées par leurs enfants alors vous
pouvez la punir le gosse n'entend plus
qu'est-ce que vous inspire les
déclarations d'Emmanuel Macron quand il
s'en prend et dénonce les réseaux
sociaux et les jeux vidéo dans les
facteurs qui peuvent expliquer cette
situation actuelle
j'ai envie j'ai envie de rire parce que
c'est vraiment le dernier
c'est le terreau de la propagation je
veux bien qu'il y ait un effet mais
c'est pas ça le c'est pas ça l'enjeu
l'enjeu c'est l'être humain là c'est le
problème avec les monsieur Macron à la
génération aujourd'hui de technocrate
qui nous gouverne ils ont oublié la
mature humaine nous ne sommes pas des
algorithmes nous ne sommes pas des codes
il y a un être humain il y a des êtres
humains en France aujourd'hui qui ne
sont pas inhibés donc ils cassent du
flic demain ils tueront un préfet ils
ont failli tué un maire hier ah là il
est rose donc ils ont pas ils ont pas
inhibé la violence ils s'empêche pas on
dirait Camus et vous et qui ne se disent
pas français c'est ça la vérité c'est ça
le driver le moteur de ce de cette
incendie les réseaux sociaux tout ça bon
c'est vous savez ils ont besoin des
accélérateurs sur messieurs mais c'est
c'est comme les armes par destination
moi avec ce micro je peux tuer quelqu'un
mais le problème mais c'est moi le
coupable c'est moi qui a la pulsion
c'est pas le micro vous avez écrit vous
venez d'écrire une autre histoire du du
colonialisme
quel est ce que vous pensez que dans les
événements qu'on vit actuellement
il y a une en tous les cas il y a une
résonance avec tout le discours sur la
colonisation malheureusement nous sommes
dans une situation qui est très qui est
très similaire à ce qui s'est passé à la
pendant la colonisation vous avez une
séparatisme territoriale c'est à dire
que dans les colonies les Français
vivaient à part les indigènes on les
appelait avant vivaient à part vous
aviez des faits divers sanglants on
disait à l'époque ce sont les hors la
loi en Algérie on disait les HLM en fait
c'était déjà l'insurrection mais qui
était travesti de banditisme vous avez
le même dialogue et même mot les blancs
les musulmans c'est la même chose qu'on
a géré par exemple et pire c'est ça qui
moi très sincèrement je suis peiné parce
que nous avons comme dans les colonies
des doutes sur les musulmans de France
ça me peine parce que certains musulmans
de France se font traiter d'arabe de
service d'autres musulmans de France
dans la police ou dans la fonction
publique ils sont me dit-on regardez
avec suspicion parce qu'on dit si on est
dans l'armée demain il y a la guerre
civile est-ce qu'il voudront défendre la
France on est revenu à une situation qui
est très similaire à la colonisation on
a eu ces problèmes là d'obédience de
double alliance c'est très triste je
pense que la mission de ma génération ce
n'est pas de dire on part à Dubaï on se
casse en Floride il faut prouver une
solution pour renouer le lien bien sûr
qu'on prendra des coups mais je pense
que le joueur la philosophe Simone Veil
disait déjà en 1942 enfin en tous les
cas avant de mourir en 1942 à Londres où
elle avait rejoint le général de Gaulle
de remède il y en a qu'un donnez-leur
quelque chose à aimer donner leur la
France à aimer est-ce que
c'est pas une partie de la solution
oui mais pas pour tout le monde je pense
je vais être très très franc très très
sincère je pense que sur 100 personnes
ah mais c'est des enfants cette
migration là peut-être que ce discours
là aimé la France 50 pourront marcher
les autres 50 ne pourront pas marcher
pourquoi parce que vous avez face à vous
une immense puissance qui est l'islam
qui est une grande machine à assimiler
l'islam assimile les Noirs les jaunes
les Indonésiens les Indiens donc vous
avez une concurrence entre deux
hyperpuissances l'Islam et la France ils
sont attirés par la France pas par
l'islam c'est très difficile avec la
laïcité ce que nous sommes devenus
une laïcité sèche pas incarnée de les
amener à nous en plus ils voient nos
dérive ou au kystes et notre faiblesse
et puis nos policiers se font rosser ils
se font caillasser ces gens-là vont pas
rejoindre la France si les symboles de
la faiblesse donc je pense qu'il faut
par contre moi ce que je veux tenter
parce que je veux pas te la Cassandre ce
que je veux tenter sur les 50 là pour
cent qu'on peut ramener à nous
développer l'idéal de l'onatum c'est pas
seulement aimé la France c'est aimer la
France pour être un homme ou une femme
qui se tient debout dans ce capitalisme
qui nous ronge dans ce dans ce
transhumanisme qui arrive dans cet
abrutissement général des masses par les
réseaux sociaux de dire retrouvons
l'idéal de l'honnêtetum
la civilisation et ça c'est ça ce que
les jeunes que vous voyez là les abrutis
qui brûlent mais peut-être pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas il manque de référent c'est
pour ça qu'ils suivent tellement
d'influenceurs et de gourous et de
rappeur sinon on leur dit le référent
maintenant c'est l'honnêtetum à la
française parce que la patrie toute
seule à mon avis elle est elle a le
souffle coupé au cours plutôt une
question qui est posée par Nicole si on
est attiré par l'Islam pourquoi on va
pas dans des pays musulmans la réponse
est que
dans l'Islam il y a un impérialisme et
l'islam soudain cette mission
inconsciente de de propager c'est ses
frontières agrandir ses frontières je
viens c'est ça ma dernière question de
riz Galli vous vous croyez plus à
l'assimilation du tout pour du tout les
faits la vérité nous crie que
l'assimilation ne marche pas
l'assimilation est un sport d'élite pour
une minorité qui veut et qui peut
s'assimiler parce que l'assimilation
c'est comme au Botanique c'est une
greffe en botanique les jardiniers vous
le diront la greffe est dangereuse
elle peut ne pas réussir et maintenant
avec WhatsApp
les diasporades ici sont connectés en
permanence à la Somalie à la Tchétchénie
au Maroc elle ne vit même plus en France
donc moi j'y crois de moins en moins
malheureusement merci beaucoup adresse
Gally français ouvrez les yeux une
radiographie de la France par un immigré
c'est comme ça en tout cas que vous
présentez votre dernier livre qui est
aux éditions de l'artilleur
effectivement parfois on sera pas
d'accord avec tout ça soulève pas mal de
questions parfois on bonit mais c'est
très intéressant et ça nourrit bien
entendu le débat merci beaucoup d'avoir
merci à vous sur le plateau pour
commenter ces dernières ces derniers
événements